من المخاطر الى اسبابها الديموغرافيه
الدينيه اصبحت عاملا ضد وحده بريطانيا
فقبل 100 عام تم انشاء ايرلندا الشماليه
على اساس انه سيضم الغالبيه البروتستانتيه
والمؤيده للبقاء في ظل لندن سبتمبر 2022
حدث تاريخي فقد الوحدويون البروتستانت
الاغلبيه وباتو اقليه امام القوميين
الكاثوليك الراغبين في الاتحاد مع جمهوريه
ايرلندا اقتصاديا كان بريك بمثابه القشه
التي قسمت ظهر البعير لكن تراجع الصناعه
البريطانيه يعود لحقبه الثمانينيات حين
كانت غلاسكو وبالباست مركزين لصناعه بناء
السفن اصابع اللوم تتجه نحو المراه
الحديديه ماركت باتشر خلال عقد من حكمها
انخفض الانتاج الصناعي في بريطانيا بنسبه
تسعه في المئه بينما ارتفع
بنسب كبيره في دول مثل فرنسا واليابان
استمراره المملكه المتحده كتحد من اربع
دول انجلترا واسكتلندا وويلز وايرلندا
الشماليه مهدد من قبل القوى الانفصاليه
فاستقلال اسكتلندا لم يتحقق في استفتاء
عام 2014 حيث صوت 55 في المئه لصالح
البقاء في المملكه المتحده ويبدو انه
سيصبح القضيه الانتخابيه الرئيسيه لسنوات
عديده قادمه مع تنامي مشاعر القوميه
وتراجع المؤيدين للبقاء الى خمسين في
المئه كما جر البريك كوتلندا خارج اوروبا
بالرغم من تصويت مواطنيها ضد الانسحاب من
الاتحاد الاوروبي وما تلاه من تبعات
اقتصاديه مكلفه الوضع في ايرلندا الشماليه
من جهته غير مشجع فحزب الشنفين الكاثوليكي
المؤيد للانفصال يقود لاول مره
المقاطعه ويضع حلم
توحيد شطري الجزيره الايرلنديه في سياسته
كثيرون هنا يقدرنا ان القوميه قد تكون
اللاعب الابرز في السنوات المقبله على
مستوى تحديد وحده المملكه